all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Bird it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and this is being filmed
so obviously I have a special guest I
don't bring any weak cupcake [__]
what's the deal with that people on I
only bring people on that I respect and
I love and this guy
is no different from I can't even say
you left that other podcast right from
from from the East Coast
he had a project that he was going to
promote you cannot promote it because of
the strike because we are union strong
bill that's right we're Union men you
need to be Dan soda everybody come on
dude uh thank you so much for having me
when they said that you I like being
part of a union it is great it makes you
this because you know why because you
and I are similar in the fact that we
feel guilty be making money from being
silly
if you don't have a union we go back to
the 1800s Industrial Revolution where
they'll have children which is what
they're getting they're they're getting
close no but they already did that they
just they just went around the unions by
leaving the country yeah by leaving the
country and then they just did the [__]
that they were doing in the 1800s
yeah and they threw up an old Playbook
and they were like we could take this
right to Mexico oh it's so dude it's so
[__] evil yeah it's so evil and then
Paul then they pay off the politicians
so they don't say anything like if you
take an American company out of America
and [__] all those Americans out of jobs
like you should be paying such
ridiculous taxes that it's not worth
your time they just don't want to pay
anybody which is why the robots are
coming it is it's why and it's why they
could have they could have brought jobs
back and made Ohio and in Michigan and
all those people happy but instead
they're like no let's just feed them
24-hour news and get them real riled up
yeah and then now they're just gonna
hate it now everyone will hate everybody
and we can just keep making our money I
know but everybody seems to know that
yet they still
like you know it's been I've been going
on and on and on and on and on about is
how everything just gets like
politicized like this is stupid [__]
post that keeps coming up my feed
because I like I look at cars and [__]
yeah on the internet and it says
um
it said it shows like some you know
killer you know muscle car and it's just
before all this electric car [__]
yeah we had muscle cars like no we
didn't muscle cars and everything
catalytic converter the [__] uh gas
prices 73 all of that [__] was gone they
ignored the Mustang 2 the Dodge opal the
Ford Fiesta the Ford Escort the Chevy
Chevette the Dodge K cars all of those
[__] cars that got they've said 60 000
miles they were designed to [__] [__]
the bed the speedometer went up to 85
miles an hour what the [__] are you
talking about there was the IROC Z the
firebird and the Grand National as far
as American cars that I can think off
the top of my head that actually had
balls everything else was just they
neutered it sucked they neutered it you
know what it is it's the same thought
when they do that with muscle cars where
they're like oh what America used to be
with muscle cars it's the same way when
you talk to your friends that are you
know we're old now they're like if I was
in high school right now I'd get so much
[__] everything would go good no you
wouldn't you go right back to that and
you'd be like I have homework I have all
this [__] I don't like this yeah I got
the seniors that I'm scared of they're
also acting like we're not in this
simultaneously with electric cars that
we're not in this ridiculous age of
horsepower with you can buy a [__]
Hellcat you can buy these amg's uh uh
[__] BMW M's those Audis I mean
there's there's so much power also we're
in 2023 right now we should be having
[__] jet packs the power should be no
we shouldn't the power should be in
space suits no we should hoverboards no
we shouldn't you don't think so at all
you don't the way but the way people
drive you want that over your house I
want I want what you've wanted and I've
I'm such a major fan of yours that I
know I want to thin the herd bill so
let's get some let's get some [__]
jet packs I think I think that that's
why they're not concerned about global
warming me too because I feel like
whatever they're gonna do and I don't
buy that if you got the jab man no the
the thing that that would kill you why
it's like why would they kill the Sheep
No we we lined up and did what they said
they want to kill the others so that I
love a conspiracy but that makes no
sense yeah they're like we got you and
you're like I don't think you do I think
you want to keep us around they're
trying to keep the Sheep around yeah why
would you yeah they're gonna have the
ones that are like difficult the people
that are bringing up the difficult
problems yeah I think it I think you're
right I think they're just going to wait
for the the world to cook most of the
people they want gone and then they'll
be like they're gonna ride it out
I think they have the technology now
here's the real Theory do you think
they're going to wait for a large amount
of people to die and then go like by the
way we can clean up the amount of carbon
dioxide and and we can we can cool the
ocean I have no idea I don't know if
it's just completely
sociopath well I'll be dead before this
happens let somebody else like I I just
think that it is so corrupt yeah and so
out of control it's like you know it's
like that ball in Indiana Jones you
can't just go
stop right there
it rolls over you so
um I'm excited to see what it's going to
look like in the next 20 to 30 years of
how they're going to divide it up and be
like you fight you know is it going to
be the scene from Dark Knight where they
break the stick and they go like I'm
hiring one person
oh I didn't see that movie but I that
sounds pretty yeah scary you just break
a stick and there's you're always hiring
one person you know the guy that walks
out of this room gets to live yeah I
just I don't have that competitive side
maybe all right just [__] stab me I
don't I mean I had a good time I mean my
my fiance and I are both agree I mean
what are you winning at that point
nothing I want to be in the blast right
now working for those [__] people I
want to be I want to be the people in
Terminator that'll you know when she's
holding onto the fence and she turns
into dust that's me that's why I live in
New York still oh if they drop that bomb
I'm just gonna hold my fiance's hand
like at the end of Fight Club and watch
all the buildings yeah I'm not gonna
fight for survival New York [__]
drives me up the wall where everybody
thinks it's so [__] badass it's not
badass it isn't it's a bus stop hey did
you see that there was another Instagram
thing like I've been I got back I was
reading I was off Instagram Instagram
drives me up the wall yeah it does it's
designed to do this New York guy like
New Yorkers are the worst traveled
people ever they go in every city today
we're all [__] building
right so this guy gets a bacon egg and
cheese sandwich I don't know where the
[__] the guy went the egg was shaped
like a [__] hockey puck anything it's
all like Hey try this in New York they'd
be like okay it's like no no one would
they do that in New York yeah there's
[__] sandwiches and this [__] pizza and
people go don't go there that place
sucks you want to go over here
had asked somebody where to go dude they
look like an Egg McMuffin like I I've
lived in I lived in Boston 27 years I
never saw bacon egg and cheese look like
that and he's all the whole [__]
that's the whole attitude where they go
like not here I remember this girl dude
they just have too many songs that are
blowing them that's it like that Alicia
Key song New York Creed jungle weird
dreams and the people at all because
they can't you know what they should do
that song with like on their head but
they're dumb ass to the side like
they're winning you living in a shoebox
for like [__] three grand a month
that song should have been Des Moines
affordable house that you can have a
backyard because everything else sucks
my favorite term I've ever heard making
fun of New Yorkers is Joe list once
called Sam Morrell a city hick he goes
he's a city hick the way that hicks
don't know how to be in big cities he
doesn't know how to be out in Rural
America they don't know how to do
anything outside of New York they're not
like I want to go get a sandwich at
three in the morning it's like well you
can't I've never understood like it's
like the whole purpose of traveling is
to experience something differently and
New York is like I came there and it
wasn't exactly like where I left ah what
the [__] I dated this girl whose parents
were from the Bronx years ago and she
couldn't understand that being from
Colorado meant that I was from a place
that had schools and Roads and hospitals
she would always be like do they have
that in Colorado it's like you burrow
trash of course 100
another thing too is the success of New
York really for the most part is other
people moving there that's the whole
reason the city's great and it's because
we went there it's because we went there
it's not because you you were George
Steinbrenner was from Cleveland Ohio
you fell out of a [__] in New York
you're not special a guy from Cleveland
Ohio bought the Yankees I love it I love
it because that feeling of they're like
well you're not in a real New Yorker
well if you if by the way Frank Sinatra
was bridging he's a [__] Jersey by
the way he's Jersey trash as someone
that just moved from Hoboken we were
living there and there was this
restaurant that they were like this was
Frank Sinatra's favorite restaurant well
it sucks ass we got the noodles and it
sucks I feel bad for Frank every [__]
place let's set that place uh that that
[__] pizza place up in Connecticut
yeah oh Frank Pepe's when they go when
Frank used to play MSG he would order
his [__] pizza from Connecticut oh
from Hertford and you were driving an
hour and a half down to him oh what a
room temperature slice dude my favorite
thing in the world is watching whenever
Joe Piscopo talks about playing Frank
Sinatra on SNL he does this like
romantic [__] thing where he's like
you know I'd walk in the room and I'd
say Frank wouldn't say that and then and
I saw in an interview they brought Phil
Hartman's which is the funniest Frank
Sinatra and he goes uh I didn't like
that they made frank mean you go Frank
was mean he was friends with the mafia
you can't be eating ice and be friends
with the mafia you're gonna be a [__]
prick and he's like and dude I love that
I love that whole idea of like Frank
wouldn't do that you're like Frank was
an old racist just because he let Sammy
Davis Jr oh man he was White Michael
Jackson for a whole [__] generation
he could do no wrong for them it's my
favorite bringing that up that Frank
Sinatra was definitely a racist is fun
and my second favorite thing is bringing
up the fact that Elvis was was he a
racist or was he normal for when he was
born was that because that that's one
thing I I make fun of people that look
at older white guys like can you believe
what they're saying it's like yeah when
were they born yeah like what you should
see as a white person is yourself if you
were born in 1938 like this is what you
would have sounded like I will walk back
to Frank Sinatra thing because he maybe
he was like Progressive for his time or
he's like I'm friends with a black guy
who's Jewish and they're like whoa
whoa two and one what is this
what are you doing
oh we can't play the n-word poker that's
what we do I like they can't do that but
the thing that you can't fight is the
fact that Elvis Presley was a pedophile
and that he married Priscilla when she
was 14 years old
I think at that point you were status
statutory rapist 14 married a 14 year
old I got one for you all right bring it
I love this the the [__] the average
age of consent in this country is 16.
that's insane I never knew that I
thought most of it was 18. I thought at
worst it was Massachusetts
is 16. I couldn't [__] believe that I
could not [__] believe that and just
just thinking about some guy going by
his house being like I'd like to take
your daughter out I know she's uh 16 and
I'm 29.
she's only 15 and a half and I was
wondering if I could have your
permission I was wondering if she's on
five months and 29 days does she have a
dating permit it's like a bigger than is
she learning how to date it you're like
what the [__] it is wild that's like Old
King [__] where they were like I want I
want a woman about to make children I
thought I thought it was from like back
in the day when it seemed like if you
worked outside you died at 30. so you
had to start early we had black lung by
the time you were 22. there was like
nobody around says like I saw a girl I'm
gonna marry her and then perverts as we
got older perverts were like don't
change that law that's a cool law there
had been guys that were like we're
holding on to that yeah why and that's
another thing that I don't understand
right like like as far as like all of
this [__] that's going on where they're
like picking apart you know everything
that everybody says and then meanwhile
there's all of this other stuff like
going why is that all right yeah Biden
smelling a girl's hair
up it gets everyone's like this [__]
weirdo I know but that is [__] weird
well that foggy-eyed old yeah who is it
was it Putin who kissed the purse the
boy's belly I mean they just [__] you
got I mean after the news that's coming
out today that that guy that tried to go
against them died in a plane crash you
let I think if you're in Russia you let
Putin do whatever you want I think he's
like Kim Jong-un where he can just walk
around and be like I'm gonna kiss your
belly and you're like yeah no you have
like he has like that heart attack
missed yeah you know you just walk by
and he goes
he's uh long gone now just like a little
problem problem cleared up Russian let
me get back on his good side hell of a
hockey player oh my God unbelievable
what did he put up like 13 goals against
the Russian national team I love that
they're like he's dick no one can defend
that's the best I think if you're gonna
be evil go all the way like American
evil seems more like marketing you know
does it yeah well like the way they do
evil here is they're like I know it
seems evil but I'm accomplishing my
goals we're in Russia they're just
because you're under the media umbrella
of their [__] yeah so and then over
there I bet a lot of people over there
was like all right you know he's got his
moments but you know it they're you're
just you're you're underneath the
atmosphere of the information that is
yeah what they're feeding us yeah that
is coming in so and then but it's it the
truth is always somewhere in the middle
sure so we're not as good as we say and
we're not as bad as other people say uh
you know yeah but somewhere in the
middle I don't see a moment where Putin
goes like
do you think I should have given that
guy plutonium I'm feeling pretty bad
like he doesn't have that moment I don't
think the the dude they're all the same
people the ones and the the higher ones
yeah and and I don't think that they're
doing that either do you think it's bad
that we put this person in power so we
could steal all the natural resources
you don't think they ever have that or
they're just like we got business done
no they always just go you know the
world is a dirty place and there's no
there's no clean way to get energy
they just have all of those that's how
they muck it up or they go like yeah
just you need energy you know what is
funny is people who for some reason just
hate electric cars and are acting like
someone saying you have to get rid of
your gas combustion car
um they're all talking about how the way
that they get you know uh whatever
natural resources they need for the
batteries yeah and then ah this is the
filthy and blah blah it's like well you
know what gas is right you know the oil
yeah you know that they find oil and
then they just take it that's what like
there hasn't been 40 wars fought for oil
and then they're like I don't know about
this electric car [__] I don't like
electric cars though I'm I'm like any
time I'll be honest with you they're
amazing they're boring that's what you
know what it is just boring they're not
fun to look at you know those those uh
rivian they look kind of interesting
which ones are those I so you gotta
understand I don't like the lights
though they look like they're wearing
like bifocals I don't know [__] about
cars that's that's why moving to New
York was a safe bet for me because it
just eliminates that whole conversation
all right because then all you got to do
is mass transportation but with electric
cars it feels like a go-kart every time
like a very powerful go-kart every time
I'm in it well what's funny is my wife
has one yeah and what's funny is to have
both our kids in it with groceries and
her in it and some guy has and you just
blow them off the [__] line I mean
they're they're uh insanely fast yeah
it's just do you think that's the way
they get the people that hate electric
cars is by being like we'll give you
like you were saying with the well my
thing was I looked at it like all right
you know
all this terrorism and stuff is coming
from the Middle East sure why do I want
to send them my money yeah so I get a
Prius yeah thinking okay I'm gonna get
this car and uh I'm doing my little part
to not use as much but then
you know the battery thing comes around
and then you just see it's just going to
be the same game yeah to get the
electric things and it's just like
that whole thing that there's no clean
way to get it is a lie what do you think
there is no what it is is the people
that are running [__] are so [__]
greedy yeah that they can't give anybody
like their fair share they want to keep
all of it that's why it's like that way
not because it's a confusing blah blah
blah it isn't it's the same game it's
the game that's going on in our business
right now they're acting like you know
there's no money gaga gaga you just
bought your third [__] Mansion yeah
they don't want to pay anybody and it's
that disease of every year you gotta
earn more yeah so it's Bob Iger going
this is not a good time for the strike
after he signs a contractor he gets 26
million a year and he's like this is
really hurting business I like at the
end of the year I've done my job so good
that I've decided I'm giving myself a
bonus it's like you're literally just
stealing back in the day the mob would
skim yeah that's what they're doing yeah
but they call it a bonus and it's
totally legal well it's even crazier
they have the balls now to get a bonus
and they go I am going to pay myself
like a lockdown Corner in the NFL I'm
going to give myself dude that was a guy
uh that that true TV guy that guy gave
himself like 150 million bucks hilarious
and he's not hitting 400 for the Blue
Jays Channel yeah he's not he's got
Impractical Jokers making all their
money and then he's like yeah you know
what no give me that [__] A-Rod deal
Bobby Bonilla day they're getting all
Bobby Bonilla paychecks for just going
like this yeah have the uh have the guy
that does street magic prank those kids
no that's not what they do they go okay
but there's three people doing that fire
two of them and now you have to do all
three of those jobs I just saved this
company money yeah give me it all of it
yeah give me all of it and then their
kids grow up and they go like my dad
really did a good job I wonder what
those children that's what I like is
it's totally it's it's it's totally
legal I'll be honest with you I find all
of this stuff overwhelming and
depressing and my reaction to it the
only thing the survival mode is I've
made my life really small even like in
LA I I just like I live like in this
much of La I just sit on my back porch I
stare at the trees yeah and I'm just
like well it's not on fire you know well
you've always been one of those guys
water's not rising up there's no robot
at my door like I I just this is a good
the robots are far away this is a good
day yeah the uh my land has not been
breached by any enemies yes do you ever
dream of that about just walking
completely away and buying a compound in
like New Zealand
uh
no I I don't like a compound I don't
want to be that guy no take the word you
know what happens
compounds eventually get overrun yeah
it's Jurassic Park eventually the fences
break down or Waco Texas it's like The
Compound thing no one's ever made it
work do you ever have the fantasy of
just going away of like you know the
helicopter coming down on the property
and you've got a big orange beard you
know and they're like Bill we need you
for 15 minutes of hilariousness and no
you know I don't do that I actually no I
like being an old guy yeah and I like uh
talking to younger comics and helping
them try to avoid [__] that happened to
me I really enjoy
that I like going to a diner getting a
cup of coffee and reading the newspaper
I like being an old [__] it's fun I
believe it sucks if you're old is if
you're trying to be young just if you
just are old it's easy it's the best I
just turned 40 and I'm loving everything
about it I'm loving not being crazy
insecure about everything worrying about
everything and then just being like ah
this is who I am but I would say you led
the road map for a lot of comics to be
like how do I fall gingers yeah but just
how do I stay funny and also like not
get because I think a lot of older guys
get so disconnected from Comedy that you
see them do stand up and you're like oh
they're not around no but I I learned
that by uh you know the guys that were
in front of me Rich Voss ahead of him
was uh you know let's say I got Dom Iraq
Chris Rock I noticed that the guys that
never stop coming around it's like you
you need to be around younger Comics so
you stay contemporary
um but what you don't do is try to be
young like look at younger Comics how
are they dressing yeah I'm obviously not
doing that
I'm having my picture taken in second
grade sure I [__] love this shirt
yeah but that's also that's also a big
part about growing older and comedy is
staying authentic because I I think
that's part of it when you see the guys
try to dress young or talk about [__] no
a young crowd will like you if you be
old yeah if you tell them like you know
like they don't want to hear you coming
up to their music you know
and then it's immediately like oh no
please tell me this is a character yeah
and you're like what's up with Tinder
and you're like you're not even on the
app dude you know when you're on Tinder
and it's just like
also my insta the other day and you're
like that's even throw up I think I'm
gonna throw it is I do love Instagram
I mean I still like Facebook oh man that
is the oldest [__] I've heard you say in
this entire I like Facebook Facebook for
me I think it's ruined for my generation
because we watched it scramble our
parents brains when they got on there oh
because my mom would send me info where
she's like can you believe this and
you're like did you click the link and
see where it was from and she's like no
oh yeah and then you're like just
watching your mom get fooled you're like
oh yeah I can't [__] do this but
she's like they said that they're doing
this you're like Mom if you click the
link you can tell it's not a real media
outlet and she's like oh I thought it
why do people do things like that
exactly always the thing why do they get
trick me but that's such a do you know
something that's such a great question
from a good person by the way why do
they have to do that do you I know it'll
happen to me I know when I'm 70 if I
make it that long and they have ai [__]
out there and all this like robot I'll
be like did you see they brought back
Ronald Reagan in the grandpa he's been
dead for 50 years and I'm like but he's
back I saw him on the news and they're
like that's AI you're like oh that was
something when I was a kid called
cryogenics do they unfreeze Walt Disney
how do you know they did none free I
need to see proof open up his back I
want to see the the power strip my
grandma's 96 and there's nothing I
respect more than her being like I'm
like Nana what about email and stuff
she's like uh get the [__] out of here
call me I'll read the newspaper I'll
watch the news she has no New Media I
don't read an email until somebody texts
me and says I I look I'll show you my
phone I have like a hundred thousand
unchecked emails and it has not affected
my life at all yeah because that's the
thing if someone texts you or calls you
yeah that's when you get like oh [__] I
mean a hundred thousand I mean it's not
it's like Santa Claus level a [__]
male like why do I have all of this
[__] milk email for like two for like
two months and I go is everything all
right you're like yeah it's fine yeah
that's so [__] funny the idea that
someone's been emailing bill being like
I just I don't know what I did to him
because you know how we take everything
personally now with all this technology
where you're like I emailed Bill guy
never wrote me back and then you're
sitting here and you're going 100 000. I
got a kid asking for a bike from [__]
two years ago no I'll tell you this if
uh like texting it like if the only
thing that makes people text you is you
texting them if you stop texting people
within three days other than your close
friends and family everybody just
because you you once you go down the
screen more than two of these it's like
you passed away I'll tell you this right
now I would even say that with phone
calls do you have those friends that you
call and if you don't keep calling them
they don't call you I got rid of all of
those people in my life and then you
know it's funny they feel like victims
that's just like dude like I just did to
you what you're doing to me
I'm not gonna name names but people are
not going to name it now but there are
people that I've like been like it's
weird because if I always call him I
don't feel like they're called
narcissists one one good friend recently
I was like I'm gonna see how just I was
like kind of like a tongue-in-cheek like
let me see how long it goes and then it
started to bum me out as the weeks went
by and I was like this [__] hasn't
called me yeah it's just been months it
was it was nothing and now you're like
and now like I have to talk about it
with Katie I have to be like hey am I
getting fired up for no reason and she's
like I would let it go and I'm like it
just I felt like he was gonna call me
but dude I had a friend I called him I
called him 90 of the time and like I
felt like 85 percent of the time he
didn't pick up the phone yeah and then
when the rare time when he would call me
and he would always the thing would
always say oh what you can't pick up the
phone it's just like this here you're
like what the [__] my favorite what is
this my favorite old school story was
that uh Patrice would always invite
Colin Quinn to his cookouts and Colin
would always say no and then Patrice
stopped calling him and then Colin got
upset and was like what the [__] you
don't invite me to your cookouts and he
was like yeah you don't come he's like I
still want to be invited they still call
me and you're like I understand that
thinking so much we're like yeah I want
you to [__] call me I want to be in
the mix I'm the opposite yeah you're
like leave me the [__] alone that you
know I'm not like anti-social but like I
just I I don't want to do anything
anymore oh I think you've done I think
that's no I do my stand up and I hang
out with my kids there's nothing better
than you know I go swimming almost every
day with my kids it's it's the easiest
it's the a pool is the greatest thing
you could ever have to to be interactive
like everybody's smiling you're buoyant
yeah you're just no gravity you're just
happy and you get you're in the position
where you get to toss them yeah throw
them around and then they're coming back
they're doing them you give them a ride
you're getting a workout you could
easily take a handful of change and
throw it and be like go get that and
they're like we're The Best Day Ever
with Dad 100 that was my favorite thing
I said to my daughter I uh did you have
a good summer and she said yeah I go how
many times did we go swimming this
Summer She Goes every day I was like yes
that's the best because you know I I uh
now that I'm 40 I'm coming out of that
hole like stay on the road if it's
Monday go do a set you gotta work a new
joke and now I'm like oh I want to spend
Monday through Wednesday just hanging
out with my fiance and my dog yeah and
watch how and it's good for your act and
then I go on stage and I'm like ah this
happened and then you're like oh oh I
have a life yeah which I I've been doing
comedy 19 years I would probably say for
like eight 17 of them I was just like
every night gotta get on stage and now
what's up with airports and hotels and
then I'm like you guys ever [__] not
sell the amount of tickets you thought
you were gonna sell and they're like how
is this a bit and then you're like oh
yeah it's inside it's too inside
baseball I'm talking about my life yeah
and now I'm getting older and I'm like
hey peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
at one in the morning give me tits and
other guys are going yeah me too and
you're like all right this is fun I'm
glad we're bonding on some [__] when do
you think we'll be able to promote our
projects that neither one of us can talk
about do you I I kept hearing that the
beginning of September I've heard if you
want
the worst news I've heard is January
okay I've heard that like studios are
prepared to go to January to [__]
[__] let them
let them and then you know what is is
like I don't know I I this this got [__]
them yeah there really is the [__] them
attitude because you see how they're
acting because what are they going to
get better
no they're not going to be nice the
greatest thing is they can hold out with
money that they've stolen from the
people that are on strike yeah all the
money they've kept they're like well I
got a yacht rented
through October I don't need to do
anything you guys can't afford your
[__] rent I'll just go to Greece yeah
he's like I would love to you know what
I'm going to follow around a European
League soccer team I'm just going to go
have you picketed I haven't picked it
yet I felt the poll I picketed and I
sent a truck and I gotta go again I sent
a food truck that's nice that wasn't my
idea because the day I picked it they
said this truck came from Snoop Dogg I'm
like does that guy just [__] knows
how to live life yeah but it's all
someone did it he was just rolling a
blunt and they're like someone was in
his ear like the president like no I
don't buy it Snoop we're gonna send
tacos and he was like this oh for sure
and he just went back to rolling a blunt
I don't think he's like there like you
know he he started a whole football
league for kids and and paid for all the
uniforms really yeah that guy's you know
that guy's is is a real anytime a
celebrity does something anytime a
celebrity does something I always assume
it's the Sarah Plain has hit the tower
where they're like doing something and
they go like oh okay like get him out of
their ear oh no I always assume the
celebrities he didn't say that he did it
I said he did it yeah if he was out
there going you know that helped the
homeless yeah they [__] they like
videotaping themselves that's my
favorite where they're doing volunteer
work as they're recording it you're like
this does not count it doesn't yeah I do
I I do feel like when I get back to New
York I'm gonna pick it I want to go pick
it because I was sent on this La trip
and I'm I'm fired up now that I came out
here no I'm I'm do I try to go uh at
least you know I don't know I try to do
something I don't have the money to send
a food truck though so that I'm just
going to be handing out cheese so just
go down there and just stand there or
whatever do you know what you do don't
beep at them when you drive by because
when you pick it it's all it's happening
every five seconds
no they're like shut the [__] off stop
it just holding their signs yeah I don't
know I would uh I would think that I
would hope it would break by the fall
but you have no idea well I will tell
you this I always knew because they they
you know it's just they've always been
this way yeah that's why I never stopped
doing stay I also love stand-up and I
had my podcast so I always had these two
things that if this [__] hit the fan
like this like you know you gotta have
you know you know you're lucky if you
have something yeah to ride this out
because uh dude the one that got me was
that that kid who's writing on the bear
you know it's a hit TV show and it's the
hottest show and he's living below the
poverty line it's just like can you just
just [__] like what do they have
against the middle class like no we hate
it nobody's asking they're not what I
love to is then people go well why
doesn't the star of the show [__] pay
him it's just like that's like you go
into a Home Depot and the guy in the
forklift's not making any money like why
don't you have the guy up at the [__]
management the thing it's like it's not
his company yeah the guy doing the
scheduling have him kick down some money
yeah for the [__] lumber yard no it's
like why can't they just uh did you see
this with uh with like because you came
up in the time of comedy clubs where
they were like
they're criminals
gone on the table I mean when they they
think they still are but now they have
to be but here's the thing now that of
podcasts now because people can Market
themselves with social media you can go
sell out a rock club that whole
alternative thing became kind of
commonplace to be like oh well if a club
won't book me I'll book a rock what's
the guy at the Rock Club that guy's not
gonna [__] you but I'm saying he didn't
have as much control over comedy when
you were coming up the comedy clubs were
like the dawns they were like hey you
want to work here jump through all these
hoops yeah I don't think Rock clubs do
that they're just like can you provide
the people then we'll book you whereas
comedy clubs were like send a tape no do
a dance now turn around and you know and
everyone was like oh okay and then all
of a sudden the comedy clubs they're
like oh these guys are playing Rock
clubs were [__] I mean one time I went
and I meddled
at the comedy Connection in uh
Providence yeah and then they gave me
host money and I called the guy up I
said I meddled and he goes no he goes
you co-hosted this is a different term I
go what does that mean I go I didn't go
on stage with the host the host brought
me up and I did buddy to buddy yeah you
say it like you're at an awards ceremony
yeah the next comic is
it's built you know yeah I did 20
minutes and they they just they've but
don't you feel like that's what these
Studio guys are doing now or they're
going like oh you wrote that show yeah
but you wrote it uh We're not gonna give
you the stream money that's like it to
me feels the same exact way
of them being like no you co-hosted
that's the money you get yeah no I think
it's it's uh
like I know I think a lot of people feel
like like capitalism is great but it has
to be monitored and it's just like it's
just completely off the [__] rails
and we're heading towards you know some
of these countries that I've been to
where you either got all the money or no
money and it's just like like that's not
good
um what was great when I was growing up
was there were a lot more unions and
there was like and people could have
like you could literally have like a
regular job you could have a factory job
or a drive a truck or something like
that and you could afford to have a
stay-at-home wife if you wanted to or
you could put your kid through college
you have to be like schools were good
and that like the fact that we've let
like in so many areas like public
schools go and and I don't think there's
anybody on either side that that doesn't
want like who the [__] wants to have to
pay College tuition starting at five
years old or whatever right like it was
also a way Public Schools were a great
way for you to be like hey this is what
life's going to be like you're going to
deal with people from all different
backgrounds yeah and put them all in the
same thing I had a huge High School my
high school was like 3 500 kids it's
like a small college so you show up and
you're like there were rich kids there
there were poor kids there and you were
just like figuring out about it we tried
we tried to give money to uh
like I was just like all right let's
just pick a public school in the area
and let's help them out and you can't do
it you have to take the money and give
it to the the the top people and then
they decide he takes off he's like I'll
take a couple oh so the only way that
we've been able to which is we're do to
do what we always we you can you can
just you can give them supplies sure so
you can go you can get like laptops
everything from pencils up to laptops
whatever they need so and
I feel like you know I like doing that
every year like that's something you
should do rather than just sitting
around bitching at it but like uh I
don't know it's kind of gonna it's it's
gonna be interesting like it at what
point
is it ever going to happen people are
going to be like look we're we're
[__] dipping into the pot too much
like do we do they have any sort of like
guilt no because I think it was what I
was talking about earlier was Putin
where there's never the moment where he
sits down he's like plutonium that might
have been too much he's always just like
yeah that's what I do I just keep moving
they're gonna keep being like no I'm a
successful businessman there should be
like a salary cap we should do salary
caps on CEOs we're just like nah you did
it you you crossed the 10 billion mark
you're done just hold on to that your
family's not going to need any more than
that you're just no I I don't I don't
have a problem with somebody making 10
million dollars 10 10 billion dollars as
long as they're leaving enough for like
a middle class because most people man
like as far as like me getting into this
business obviously you know you want to
make it but I just wanted to be able to
like not have a day job and be able to
pay my rent telling jokes and it's just
like for a lot of people
who are [__] that's enough yeah I
think that's what everyone wants they
just want to be able to afford their
rent be able to yeah eat and then have
like a thing that brings them Joy I got
season tickets to the Niners I got
season tickets to something and they're
like I like to go fishing or I go
hunting or whatever the hell you just
have your hobby yes and be able to live
like that's the out of everything that
I've seen growing up like watching that
go away and then just watching people
yelling about the color of ties as it's
happening it's kind of like it's just
like
guys what we all want the same [__]
we're all trying to be comfortable yeah
and the reason and they're they're just
like they're just putting us in like uh
like they fight dogs they just got us in
like the pit and um they're great at it
though they're because they're great at
aiming us at each other well that's why
they used to have rules on media
ownership once they deregulated that and
then you know you you got dead Ted
Turner's View and you have uh not Ralph
Macchio what's the other guy's name the
Karate Kid
Rupert Murdoch yeah I know who's
Australia I know it was RM yeah
my favorite fact is always that he's
Australian
and he's just and he's just running the
biggest pro-america news site and you're
like that's it's a foreign you can blame
CNN for Fox News because if CNN didn't
do it yeah oh no CNN's just as guilty
they're all guilty all of them are [__]
CNN's the worst also the 20. I don't
like CNN because they pretend that they
care yeah so does MSNBC they go like
msnbc's your mom coming in after your
dad yells and being like
it's pretty crazy MSN but you don't know
in the kitchen she was like [__]
ground his ass ground his ass and then
she comes this NBC to me is like prog
rock or something like I don't even like
like what is is that's not in four I
can't listen to that I don't even I
don't even know what channel that's on
no like there's never any news on
in my every once in a while my
mother-in-law will come over we'll come
over and she'll have like CNN on and
I'll walk in a room within three minutes
I have like a panic attack I'm like can
you [__] this the graphics the noises
the way they go like everything is
always breaking news ever on CNN you
can't turn on CNN without there being
breaking news Well Fox is the same way
and all they do is just like blame each
other and it's like like it's so [__]
Un-American so am I when I run for
office okay all right I'd get destroyed
I'm capping people at 10 billion you get
10 billion but then anything over that
you got to kick back down to make a
middle class again and they're only you
can only have the news in the morning
and at night like when we were growing
up you can only have the Nightly News
and The Morning News and then stop
trying to fill 1pm to 5 p.m with
buzzworthy [__] well I would go back to
I would just go back to the national
news and the local news and then the
person reading it cannot show you which
way they lean yeah they have to be very
like big fat Thai yep and just being
like today there's still going to be
propaganda sure but I'm fine with listen
as an American that loves this country
give me a little American propaganda but
it's like just a little spice I just
need a little I don't need it the whole
thing I don't need it covered in ranch I
need a little give me a Dazzle a little
drizzle of rain I love it I love the
City Orchestra and the fireworks show
yeah and people out on boats shooting
[__] oh my God I love old men in
uniforms marching and being like I can't
sleep and when a book drops I [__] my
pants I love that I love that but let's
get back to like just the news being oh
here comes the news here's the
information the who what where and why
not like do you think Joe Biden naps too
much like probably he can barely stand
at this point I can't believe
he's going to make another election they
shouldn't that's it's the dumbest thing
I've heard the dumbest thing I've heard
it's like the yaromir Jagr of
politicians like he's gonna play another
season and go sit out sit out Jeff
George I know you still got something
left in the arm but you're throwing a
lot of picks he just shows up he's like
yeah it's [__] wild it is absolutely
wild the [__] dude it's insane those
guys should be like just just stick them
on a porch somewhere Shane kills had a
line that cracked me up or he goes he's
the only President you could assassinate
with a punch and you're like it's so
goddamn funny that's so goddamn funny he
really is lately though that is like I
don't know that Trump could Trump is 80
and eats McDonald's I love it as a
McDonald's fan it gives me hope for the
future that I could keep going on that
science meet I know but I think but he's
got the money to just he gets him
blasted all four blasted out every six
months you know he's just a guy with a
big brother he probably has it he has a
zipper
they just pull it out and they're like
there you go get that out I think the
more we see with the wealth disparity
the more and more people get wealthier
and wealthier and then the easier it
gets to get a Gun there's just going to
be a moment where those rich people are
like did you guys notice all these poor
people are strapped outside of our
[__] compounds no they they do you
think they'll squash it before it
becomes a problem they have the elite
weapons well that's the thing you know
when people like they talk about you
know
you know the right to bear arms in in
which I totally understand but when they
say that you know you know I want to be
able to fight off a tyrannical
government it's like first of all what
are you waiting for and secondly like
whatever Weaponry you have access to as
far as you being able to fight off the
government or watch the weapons they
have in technology that ship sailed
somewhere around World War one once they
put a machine gun on a plane they're
kind of [__] yeah your zero chance
you're gonna beat that with your [__]
nine millimeter at your house or even if
you got a like a fully automatic weapon
it's just you like they're gonna they
can they got guys in [__] Arizona
blowing people up on the other side of
the world with [__] drones like what
are you gonna get at the local gun store
yeah then it is funny that some dude you
know a whole family in Yemen's getting
taken out and then a guy in Arizona
leaves his little [__] Locker outside
and then goes to like a Tilted Kilt and
it's just having pictures of beer I
don't think I think it [__] with them
you think so well dude I never watch
videos like that and I'm going to uh
you know doing a run of dates in Europe
and uh you know the comics I'm going
with to go you know because they know
I'm a terrified of the ocean they go
what about the Mediterranean Sea there's
no [__] I always say there's no sharks
there I go there are sharks so I I
Googled shark attack and this [__]
guy Man Poor kid this this this Russian
kid was on vacation and got eaten by a
tiger shark and like I I just I was
you're just gonna see the tail and him
and him just go I mean it was like a
movie where they make it look you saw
them it was brutal because in a movie
they just go under there I never watch
like real
death [__] like when I remember like
when you know those people getting their
heads sawed off all right she's just
talking about it
yeah people would like be did you see
that it's like no I don't want to see
that do you remember when Isis but
anyways get into that like yeah this
[__] guy
I mean dude this thing came in the
second time it bit him it came in right
at his shoulder and just [__] dude
took him under like a piece of paper
yeah gone yeah [__] gone and it was
just like I don't know what the why did
I even bring this up well we're talking
about uh fear of uh we were talking
about weaponry and then we're talking
about you guys oh and so just just
watching that yeah watching this poor
kid get killed and like you know the
only thing you could hope for was it was
just that last bite just yeah you're
hoping it you know like but if you
actually are killing people
like it's it's just it's I would say
it's a new form
of whatever the you know the soldiers
that come back and actually face
somebody and do it at there's got to be
some sort of you know new form of PT I
always thought PTSD PTSD do you think
they leave so you think they leave their
crate in the middle of the desert in
that like [__] thing they have them
in with all the controls and you think
they leave and they're like wow I
[__] I saw it I would actually think
that it would depend on what you did
like if you were saving troops lives
like you oh my God there's you know some
people over here they're gonna hurt our
guys and you say to them I think that
would be a different feeling than you
know what happens a lot is [__] up
and you kill the wrong person and then
you just like
all right wasn't on purpose I was doing
my job that's stuff like uh as someone
that's [__] up a lot at work in any
job I've ever had well there's a reason
why we're doing this and not doing that
yeah but I could see me being with a
headset going like this and like all
right Soldier and launch those drones I
go
I think it was a hospital I think they
go what
and I go I [__] I think I just blew
up a hospital I gotta take the headset
off and they're like God damn it that
would be me I would be the guy coming
out of the thing being like I [__] up
I [__] up big time I [__] got a
whole wedding it was a wedding I think
that they would they would see that in
you psychologically before they wouldn't
even put me on the controls yeah but we
could well because
are you know you're there protecting our
sides so they don't want you they don't
want some wishy-washy
[__] guy let me go like this are you
guys mad at me yeah you just [__] I'm
so worried about it sorry guys sorry I
think I just shot two missiles into a
bridal party yeah no this it's uh you
know that's what I think is funny too
when they talk of like older people now
saying this generation soft it's like
they've been fighting a war I don't I
don't think they're soft I think every
generation has some soft people but like
you know like uh one of the homeless
population we're really talking deep
[__] here a lot of the homeless
population out here is like you know
it's like you know wild yeah veterans
and stuff and what's Wild for me is that
the the the the experience now of being
like a veteran it's like you you
enlist yeah you get brought out halftime
at a football game get a standing
ovation and then you serve yeah come
back with all the problems you end up
homeless and then the same people that
gave you a standing ovation 18 months
earlier are driving by going I get a job
you [__] piece of [__] I had a line I
was I was joking around about that I had
a line in a bit where I was like oh so
uh there's a guy on the street like I
liberated Fallujah now you won't let me
inside and people were like oh oh every
time I would say that you're like but
that's just the truth right you got all
these guys they stay out here those are
our sidewalks it's like it's his it's
their sidewalks too and there's a funny
is nobody uses the sidewalks out here no
no one walks anywhere yeah we drive
everywhere we go let them where the [__]
are they gonna go guys sleeping in a
tent made out of garbage bags on a 100
degree day inside of that and we're like
no but you're right half time
suffering enough keep it moving yeah
it's it's it is wild to me that we have
no real great programs for soldiers to
come home to and be like we have better
programs for prisoners to get out of
jail than we do for vets to come home
and be like you dealing with some stuff
put them out there it's [__] wild
yeah this is one of the most we can't
end the podcast this is depressing we
got to talk about some good [__] oh it's
good yeah got a lot of new football
stadiums and baseball stadiums stuff's
good there's a lot of tastes being made
do you ever have chipotle ranch it's
incredible that's great by the way we do
have to Smashburger movement juicy on
the inside crispy on the outside how did
you go when you're when your daughters
when you're when your kids have kids and
they're like Grandpa how'd you deal with
it you're like well I had never had a
zesty jalapeno taste before or endless
Coca-Cola that was pretty sweet the [__]
we have to distract us is the best [__]
ever I mean it's it's the [__]
coolest it's pretty well it's the cool
having a pool anywhere remember when
like only one person you knew had a pool
or like oh you were Rich a person a
person that knew a person you knew had a
pool and you'd be like can we get over
there yeah and now people are like we
can build that we can build that you
know what's funny too is whatever I was
a kid like you just moved into a house
and you said eventually we're going to
redo That Hideous room and you never did
no but now people like they like the
whole thing has to be redone to their
exact that's because there's 50 shows on
television about how we can blow that
wall out we'll make it an open space I
don't like that backsplash like I didn't
I didn't even know that that word that
word just came into my life dude I
remember my stepdad was the most handy
guy ever he built my mom a 1970 MGB in
our garage just built it wow just with
the body
yeah oh that was I saw one of those
today yeah just saw one of those it was
[__] phenomenal you built her that
hatchback yeah yeah and he he built it
you know he got the body and then built
it it was like the most handy guy and
never sat in the garage with him I was
always like I'm gonna watch wrestling
and he's like I'm gonna build stuff I
should have done that but I remember we
moved into this house and my mom was
like oh I want a garden you know it's
like one of those things and this is the
90s or it was like well then do it
yourself and my stepdad was like I'll
build you one and like I watched him put
in a sprinkler system and all this [__]
and I was like how do you know to do
this he's like this is it and now if you
buy a house you're like I'm not moving
until the garden's built have someone go
build me a garden and you're like it's
you can just do it like that it was my
stepdad I think that caused their
divorce so it was like that was a big
enough Garden to be like was that worth
it Mom rushing divorces
start bitching at each other all this
stuff he's like I built your garden that
was always like the thing I built your
goddamn 1970 MGB and my mom's like
that's the male version of I gave you
children that's exactly it and I watched
it and I remember being a little kid
watching it being like he's got a point
that guy put a lot of time into that
Garden
at well I mean that's one of the uh
that's one of the it's the comedy of
being a married guy yeah I'm about to
enter that moment yeah it's worth you
know it's definitely worth it but the
the water definitely flows
you know look once every 15 years we get
a tropical storm out here
the rest of the time it's just the water
you know which way the water goes that's
[__] hilarious I'm gonna take that's
possibly the best advice I've gotten
for being engaged is you're just like
just know which way the water goes yeah
and occasionally you get your day well
yeah there's there's
yeah it's I'm not going to tell you
anything new but it is what it is it's
definitely worth it having kids is
[__] awesome and all that type of
stuff but the water flows
I'm gonna get that [__] tattooed on
my arm so next time I'm in the kitchen
yelling so I'm gonna be like okay no I
got it yeah you're right yeah you're
right why did I do that I'm Gonna Save
myself a weekend of pain no the only way
to beat it you can't argue the river
what you can do is if you quietly accept
the river the river starts to feel a
little bad about what it's doing and
then it checks in with you is everything
okay this is the Bruce Lee 3B water
speech for guys getting married be water
just flow just don't push against it
just be like they know what they're
doing yeah and you go along with it and
then when you get a little like don't
argue you just get quiet when you get
quiet then they start thinking like all
right I've been pushing a little too
hard that's so far that's all it is but
if you actually if you face it yeah oh
yeah no then it's like then it rages
over undertow
do they find they find your body down in
San Diego the next time I'm gonna start
an argument or whatever I'm just gonna
the the one word of undertow is Gonna
Come into my head I'm like not just go
with the flow be like yeah you're right
just quiet just float just back float
let the water take you they know you're
doing [__] you don't want to be doing
yeah okay so if you're just cool then
they'll just keep doing it but every
once in a while if you just get quiet
then they're like hey yeah like or they
come and sit down next to you how you
doing you're just like good I'm all
right doing all right is everything all
right you know it's fine I have to hide
that then then that that
[__] with them so then they gotta be
like wow
how are you are you you don't seem like
you're fine I think you should do a bit
about that yeah you don't seem like if
they give you the little forearm thing
next on the couch they go what are you
doing is there a game on her or
something today
good yeah maybe if you're a guy you like
games maybe later and they're like do
you want to just hang out today it's
like yeah oh dude that's [__]
hilarious I'm absolutely taking that
advice yeah don't get ripped into the
undertow yeah and then what you do in
the meantime is you know you go out and
get coffee with them you take them to
the movies and stuff so you keep it
alive there's a bad thing don't start
drifting yeah don't start drifting
because you'll get to a point where you
can't come back together and then you
got to go out and [__] find somebody
new and then these [__] idiot guys
that I love these guys that get divorced
that and then get married again I get
getting divorced you were out yeah and
then you go back in like it's gonna be
different yeah like the water is going
to flow the other way it's not the water
goes one way no bill this undertow
understands this River's gonna be
different it's not
I think that was probably the most
positive thing we've said on this
podcast
yeah I think it's good relationship
advice well I'll say that I'll hit
something positive is I I it people
wouldn't know smelly but I do like
people and I I like listening different
points of view and I don't care if
you're conservative or if you're liberal
and I don't think that's a bad thing and
I think that it's funny that like uh
like liberals call you you're a Centrist
like it's bad it's like yeah I am yeah I
am you know what I'm doing I'm hearing
both points yes I hear both sides and
then whatever sounds good to me I go
with because I know that nobody is Right
100 of the time you [__] lunatic and
it's also the thing you said where
they're always hiding it's poker they're
always they have poker faces on so you
don't know what they're actually
thinking yeah I hope we get back to the
point where it was like back in the day
where no one talked about religion or
politics they're just like I don't I'm
not gonna tell you who I voted for and
you're like let's just keep it that way
exactly don't bring that up we still
shouldn't do that yeah I love that I
love when I'm like I don't know I got
another positive one yeah it's not about
Dairy Queen the best Dairy Queen's still
around the best the blizzard it's fought
through McFlurries it's father all these
imitators
yeah I like the black and white soft
serve ones yeah that's what no racial
Harmony look at that coming together you
know what our nice tasty treats I like
when they put the spoon in and they show
you yeah look at that fantastic it holds
and you're like exactly one of the worst
things that happened to me in America I
was [__] I think I was in Portland
Oregon and I ordered some mint chocolate
chip when they told me it wasn't in
season that's it was in San Francisco
that's what so I went across the street
to the drugstore where all the old
people were and guess what they had
gallons
gallons of lime green lime green lime
green mint chocolate chip I don't want
your [__] white white chocolate chip
what is this [__] I want it green I want
it Incredible Hulk green yes I'm an
American I will have mint chocolate chip
any [__] day of the month and for all
you people that say it tastes like
toothpaste well [__] you maybe I like
that taste it did mint chocolate chip
[__] rules it does rule dad you fired
me up I'm gonna go get Dairy Queen
I might stop by there after this
um all right well it was fun not
promoting all the cool things you had
coming out I uh honestly have listened
to this podcast for [__] 12 years
however long you've been doing it and
when you said yes I was like this is
unbelievable it was unbelievable to me
yeah man you know I've been having a lot
of guests lately I'm trying to get back
to not doing it so and I think I hope I
I hope I [__] you know this was such
a positive
conversation no I like having I do like
having guests especially because I don't
I don't see you a lot yeah are you being
on the East you know in New York City
where are we doing
why can't I get Starbucks at two in the
morning you can in New York no you can't
now you're [__] there's so much
there's plenty of bad pizza and bad
Bagels in New York they're all living
off the reputation you need to talk to a
New Yorker that tells you where the [__]
to go by the way why would Boston be any
different of course you can get a bad
bacon egg and cheese there you can also
get a great one if you ask somebody you
dumb [__] it's called having local
knowledge also I trust the New Yorkers
that grew up there have left and came
back and still celebrated because you're
like all right you've understood that
there's other things in the world
they're not the cocky ones it's the ones
that have never left
all right that's it everybody this has
been the podcast thank you to Dan Soder
check them out on the road check out all
his [__] that he can't promote and have
a great weekend you [__]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast from Monday
August 31st
2015 August 31st as far as I know it's
the last day of [__] summer
maybe it isn't maybe some of you
consider uh Labor Day
you know maybe some of you those
traditionalists where you can't wear
white after Labor Day
well tell it to that [__] that was on
that thing last night that [__] uh
doesn't show videos anymore
um I am of course talking about the uh
the MTV Music Awards which I gotta be
honest with you I didn't even know that
they were on
you had no idea my wife uh knew and she
put them on
and
um I'm at one point they was in the
background they were showing the the old
MTV logo and it was changing all colors
and stuff
and I just I always get sad when I see
it like what happened
what happened where the [__] did they
get off and I know I'm the one millionth
person to say this but where the [__] do
they get off
why do they have a video
um music awards when they don't show any
music videos
you know what I mean do I do I have uh
I don't know do what do I host a [__]
show about not being a [__]
laughs
that would be just as hypocritical right
by the way could that chick be trying
any [__] harder
good Lord
we get it
those dumbass outfits
you know every [__] outfit looking
like you're gonna go [__] Captain Kirk
it's so I
go back and look look at some of the the
truly shocking [__] that people did way
back I thought you know who [__]
freak me out a long time ago was Marilyn
Manson the first time that guy came out
he sang The Beautiful People and he was
I don't know what the [__] he was
wearing it was something I think it was
that thing that women wore back in the
day when they try to make their waist
really small is that a corset
he had that and like his [__] awful
ass hanging out and he had like these
contact lenses that made him look like a
husky
[Music]
what the [__] the [__] is that you know
running around
not the jail bait with the [__]
tongue hanging out and now you're legal
and
I was in the other room right
and uh
you know my wife has some family in town
so
she and some of the ladies were in there
watching it and uh
so the [__] uh
Captain Kirk's one night stand there
what the [__] is her name I want to keep
saying Lady Gaga I know it's not that
it's not Taylor Swift that's two out of
three though
um
Miley Cyrus
Miley Cyrus so she's in there
singing this [__] song over and over
again about how she doesn't give a [__]
and uh
I felt bad for her
you know what I mean because you know
with the music game it's like yeah
you're popular for a while and then it
just [__] starts to go down
and then maybe you get one more hit and
then you [__] finished and then for
the rest of your life you gotta sing
those songs
tonight
why do you think Billy Joel drinks so
much he's got to sing the same [__]
20 songs for 40 years I mean the fact
that that man is still standing
is a testament
to his inner strength
if I had to do the same [__] jokes
for 20 years
40 40 years you're going back to [__]
uh
I didn't want to do jokes I did [__]
four years ago there's no way these
these poor people and this poor woman
Miley Cyrus is gonna have to sing about
how she doesn't give a [__] when she's
in her 50s and 60s
you know what I mean and she's painted
herself into a corner wearing those Star
Trek outfits
no she hasn't
she if I was her manager I say listen at
some point
you got to put your tongue away and and
put some goddamn clothes on or uh you
know I'm I'm Gonna Leave right around
when you're about 32-33 because I'm not
going to watch this [__] train wreck
like what's her face uh Madonna I mean
Madonna's pushing 60 and she still has
to go out there and fishnets Rubber and
a clam because that's what got her there
you know what I mean I mean she should
be like I mean she's a month so
somebody's mom she has like grown-up
kids
she's still trying to hide behind that
well I'm trying to break down the
boundaries of what you picture when you
picture a 58 year old woman yeah
you're really not it's just like uh
growing up and having a little bit of
class and admitting that you know those
days are behind you
and enjoying your kids right that's what
I would think
you run around
wait a minute I mean an old rock stars
still running around grabbing their
dicks I know God knows Billy Idol is
um I don't know maybe I'm wrong on this
one I have no idea but you really gotta
I I would think if I was a musician
which I'm clearly not
in the back of my head as much as I had
to be present and who the [__] I was
when I was writing songs there would be
something that's going like hey you know
if this is a giant hit I'm gonna have to
sing this in a casino when I'm 60.
you know what I mean
it's gonna be 60 years old going yeah
smoke weed
I don't give a [__] right [__] jelly
rolls hanging out of that [__] outfit
um
I don't know the [__] do I know
all you got to do maybe just give it a
funny intro
it's behind this next song I wrote when
I was 21 within the first half of line
of lyrics You're Gonna realize it
forgive me as I roll my eyes when I sing
this [__] thing
um
oh my God Jesus Christ
that's going to come back to honey I
worry about that you know
about ever becoming a [__] parent you
know
is uh
some of the bits that I've done coming
back and blowing back in my face you
know what I mean
you know I'm I was an idiot and I kind
of still am but uh legally you have to
do what I say within reason
sorry
would you like some fruit loops um
I don't know how you do it you notice I
don't give a [__] about any of those
things those [__] video awards you
know what it really is I just wish that
MTV still played music so I could stay
up on it rather than just no one who
liked the the five pop stars are
you know what I mean
like how many times are they going to
keep going back to Taylor Swift and
Kanye West that's just like is there
anybody new Kanye West Taylor Swift
Miley Cyrus
[__] uh uh that chick there with the
booty
the [__] is her name she's always
arguing with people on Twitter
I just had it Nicki Minaj
those same four people have been on
every [__] that same awards show for
like 10 years at this point
I see that show like once every three
[__] years it's the same goddamn
people even Justin Timberlake went home
at some point like guys sister they
don't show videos anymore it's [__]
over
right
I don't know what the [__] do I know um
anyways uh this is the Monday Morning
podcast I'm running my Yap here and uh
dude this is the last day of August and
which means obviously tomorrow is
September 1st in September I'm gonna go
out of the limb here and say this is the
greatest [__] month of the year and
starts the greatest four months of the
year
it's football season
baseball is is is
hurtling towards the [__] uh hurdling
or hurling
cruising we'll pick a word I can use
Cruise towards the playoffs
hockey and hoop start up
right you got Thanksgiving which is the
[__]
and then you got Christmas which is
awesome
if you married the right person
or you're not in jail
right I always heard the holidays are
rough when you [__] lock down if
anybody's listening to this somehow in
jail
um
I don't know what to tell you I'm sorry
about that you know I hope you're ready
no I don't hope you're innocent I hope
you did it Jesus Christ you're gonna sit
there eating that [__] slop
um anyways
I wonder if they actually have a
reprieve in prison during the holidays
you know what I mean like for like one
day everyone can just walk around the
yard and act like it's like Central Park
uh the idea the idealistic version of
Central Park where you can just sort of
skip around with birds like you're in a
Walt Disney movie you know without the
anti-Semitism of Walt
Walt
oh Walt they're not all bad how many
times do you think they said that to MSU
was drawing Pluto
um
anyways so my big plans for this week
aside from this is the final [__]
week of my diet to get down to the
weight that I want to be at
um Thursday afternoon I'm going to a
second
and I say Thursday afternoon because the
games come on early out here and I'm
gonna watch
the beginning
of of the Michigan Wolverines turning
their football program around
huh
making the Ohio State Michigan game an
actual Factor again for the first time
in 15 years
Jim Harbaugh
I'm telling you if you you guys got us
if he didn't look at it already just
Google a picture Jim Harbaugh first
pitch Detroit Tigers
just look at that that guy is a [__]
animal he's a maniac he's such a psycho
grown men at the professional level
couldn't handle them anymore in San
Francisco and now he's going to Michigan
where they don't make any money at least
legally right
they gotta do what the [__] he says I'm
telling you within two years this guy's
gonna turn this thing around I think
they're going to make major leaps I'm
hoping they are and all of a sudden that
song will be able to be sung with pride
again
come on Buckeye fans sing it with me huh
Hail to the Victor's Valiant Hail to the
Victor's Valiant hail hail to be shaking
the something and something
um
you know I think the number one reason
why Ohio States hates uh Michigan is
because they don't have as good a fight
song nobody knows what the fight song is
for Ohio State they don't as much as
Woody Hayes jumped up and down and had a
temper tantrum nobody gave a [__] about
that song I don't know why there's like
three songs that everybody knows they
know that one and then they know
Jesus loves us [__] best and then the
USC Trojans which is the worst I feel
like I could have wrote that song
do they play that song The Reason number
one reason why I [__] hate USC
is uh well when I was younger I was a
Notre Dame fan and somewhere around Lou
Holtz I've talked about this before one
sometime around Lou Holtz when he was
holier than thou and go yeah
all that dumb [__] and he was just like
trying to claim that they weren't doing
steroids yet they were just as big as
teams that were doing steroids it's just
that that classic religious God loves us
best touchdown Jesus horseshoe once I
got older it started to annoy me but
when they got really bad I don't want to
see that happen the same way I hated
watching Michigan get really bad I would
hate to see that happen to Ohio State
and I'm one of those weird people
because I lived in Massachusetts
um
I like Ohio State and Michigan which
makes no [__] sense but I like both
of them and I want them to be both be
great and kick the [__] out of each
other in November is that asking too
much I don't think it is
but getting back to USC those
[__] play
that song which isn't a bad song it's
just they Pummel you with it it's like a
[__] Beyonce song by the end of the
first quarter it's like I got it this
song has been released
if I if I pay 99 Cents and download it
on the iTunes can you stop playing it at
least for eight [__] seconds those
stupid [__] at USC
okay they play that song every they they
they break the Huddle and they play it
like that was some accomplishment hey
they're all on the same page and they're
gonna try to execute this play it drives
me up the [__] wall like whenever I
watch a USC game I just have my thumb on
the mute button and I swear to God by
the end of it I have like is it possible
to have carpal tunnel in your thumb or
whatever whatever the the [__] tendon
is in my forearm it's a little sore
there right
and then when I watched the late game I
got my forearm and Ben Gay
um what the [__] I'm talking about so
anyways this is um
so I had my way in yesterday I'm
actually doing this podcast Monday
morning I've been doing them Sunday
nights recently but uh so I had my way
in yesterday I had to get down to 165
um after a loss last week
and the question was
was uh oh Billy [__] flabby tits
gonna be six wait let me let's see I'm
about to [__] my record is I know I had
two losses
all right first week I went down to 183
then down to 180 then I had a loss then
177 174 171 then I had a loss
then uh
no I won that one then I lost the next
week
all right so this this week would be to
see if I'd be five and three or six and
two
five and three The Season's starting to
slip away
is there trouble in Freckle town
had to get down to a buck 65 and God
damn it I got on the scale and I was
drum roll 165.0
made it I made it I'm like a lady I had
to go [__] skip rope for a couple of
rounds to drop some water weight to make
weight and my buddy goes dude that's
cheating I'm like no it isn't it's not
[__] cheating all right
your negative [__] it's not [__]
cheating Fighters do that all the time
to make weight all I'm trying to do is
make white and I I I've weighed myself
throughout all of this right after I
worked out that is when I've weighed
myself so that is consistent now I know
that I weigh a couple more pounds over
that maybe even three more pounds over
that all right but this is working for
me so shut your [__] pie hole
so this is the deal when I get down to a
buck 62 next week
which is the weight I want it to be so
I'll be 162 after my workout all right
now what what most people do at that
point they go hey I made it now I'm
gonna have a cheeseburger and fries and
become a [__] addict again Sugar's
all true salt sugar is all right doing
that [__] what I'm going to then do is
try to
I'm going to start weighing myself after
lunch seeing what that number is and
then I'll get down to 162. weighing
myself after lunch every day so there
you go I'm doing it in baby steps go
[__] yourself I'm an old man
um
so anyways uh yeah I'm psyched
I knew if I talked about this [__] on
the podcast I would have done it because
if I didn't if I was just doing it on my
own
and I didn't have you guys
hypothetically in my [__] ear giving
me [__]
that I'm a loser because I didn't make
it uh I probably would have stopped
around a buck 72. hey I'm looking pretty
good yeah
yeah I think I could have a [__]
cookie
um but this morning uh today's like
technically my day off so uh on my day
off I still go do something because I'm
at that age if I take a day off I'm
still [__] even if I eat well I don't
understand it I have to do something so
um every fourth day my day off right
I do chest and tries I do the [__] uh
pull-ups and all that [__] the next day
and then the next day I do legs and then
on my day off
I have to do something go for a walk or
whatever but lately I've been riding a
bike and uh so I'm riding up
through the [__] Hills out here
and uh I'm [__] dying
right I'm standing up in first and like
first
like the the easiest gear and I'm
probably like gear six you know we got
you got one two and three as far as
level difficulty I'm on one and I think
I'm on gear four and I'm standing up
like ah
every [__] you know pedal that I'm
doing right every Revolution and then
I'm hearing this guy coming right up
behind me and I'm just going oh [__]
this you know here comes one of these
[__] guys just gonna [__] blow by
me and this dude I thought I thought it
was gonna be somebody in their 20s maybe
early 30s this [__] old man
with his old legs with the elasticity
and his legs gone [__] blows by me
Blows By Me still sitting in his seat on
the bicycle didn't even say hello he
just went right by me
I'm not even joking I know that sounds
like a hacky [__] joke I swear to God
and then
within two turns I couldn't see him
anymore he was gone
and I was looking all the way up the
hill and I just see this [__] little
guy all the way up the hill
you know I was riding through the
Canyons there I'm looking all the way to
Hill going that's not him and I'm trying
to look
like between that guy whoever the [__]
that guy is and me as we're going around
the turn it turned out it was him he
just [__] smoked absolutely smoked me
but um
whatever what are you gonna do but you
know it's been motivate me to ride the
bike every every fourth day it was Versi
firstly going dude getting a bike at
your end no that's the biggest [__]
waste of money that's in my head every
time I look at the bike
I'm like I gotta [__] put 100 miles
on that bike by the end of this year
you know because verzie
is coming out this year I believe he's
going to go to the Rose Bowl with this
so at some point when I'm hammered
I'm gonna have to say it to him verzie
not for [__] nothing not for nothing
I put 100 my 100 miles on that bicycle
huh look at this
look at that [__] stomach it's flat
all right
um
you know what kills me is I'm basically
at a weight where I used to have abs and
I don't anymore because once you get the
[__] stomach you're done and I've
been watching all these videos on how to
get the [__] last
you know right now I I have what the CL
I have the quintessential [__] belly
like you could you could
you could [__] put me
uh I'm gonna warn you right now this is
gonna be such a horrific visual but I
gotta do it you could put me in a pair
of ladies bikini bottoms right
and just just take a picture of my belly
hanging over them and nothing else and
you would think it was a chick
be like oh that's adorable I wonder how
old her title her toddler is I have a
little bit of baby fatty I got a baby
bump
it's almost worse than my beer belly the
beer belly was really masculine you know
what I mean it was becoming a big
[__] teddy bear like ah you know you
know women love when that guy's a little
fat
they love that [__]
you know no other women are going to be
looking at them they don't have to be
intimidated that he's looking at her in
a certain [__] way because you know
he's over there crushing it on the
elliptical they like it they like when
you have [__] dope
that's like my wife she will not give me
a [__] compliment I swear to God I
swear to God
you know they say you go out and and
like you know you end up marrying
somebody just like your mom my mom was
like that my mom I swear to God
never
never gave out compliments ever
you know
and I was thinking with ah Nia you know
she's so [__]
positive she says unbelie this is force
her personality is incredible
but when it you know whenever I'm
[__] doing something like you know I
learned something on the drums
I go up and crush it as a comic or
whatever like never
not a [__] peep
not a peep
she says it to her friends I hear her
compliments to me through her [__]
friends that's how I hear it so the
whole time right I'm sitting there you
know as I'm dropping the weight you know
I'm going huh check it out I'm looking
good right am I looking good she'd be
like yeah you're looking good
I'm like come on man we've dropped like
[__] six pounds she's like Bill I
said you look good Jesus Christ like
that's the best I would get out of her
and I'm such an insecure [__] I keep
coming back you know like looking for
this like this parental approval
from her I gotta I gotta get past that
that's what I've learned throughout all
this
I know I look good
I don't need her
um anyways what the [__] am I talking
about here uh 21 minutes in Jesus Christ
it's time for a little bit of
advertising here
um so that's the deal dude so I'm I'm
I'm not gonna lie to do it I like to
make weight this week because I [__]
up so bad the previous week
uh I got on the scale and I was 165.8
and then I went in the garage and I
finished my workout and then just to
make doubly sure I skipped rope for six
rounds
um
just pouring sweat and then I came back
in and I got on the scale and I was like
163 point something which I know is
[__] I'm probably about honestly
after lunch walking around I'm probably
like 167 168 but I made weight so go
[__] yourself that's a victory all right
you can't get me I want it on a
technicality this isn't some Belichick
cheating it was more Jim ersei in that
I'm not going to get in trouble for it
can't believe it can't [__] wait
I love September
I love the end I'm one of those people I
love the end of the year and the
beginning of the year it's these middle
[__] months here that drive me
[__] nuts with the summer heat I love
the beginning of the year where it's
like oh man [__] a whole year
clean slate
what are we gonna try to [__] fix
what are we gonna try to get better at
all that type of [__] what do I want to
do right and then I love the end of the
end of the year
you know
because it's just like man I'm so happy
to have these people in my life man you
know and it's football it's [__]
great it's it's really
I think it's just August I [__] hate
August
I don't hate it hate it I just it's just
too [__] hot living out here in the
desert
living out here in the desert
um all right let's get to the [__] uh
let's get to the things here oh by the
way by the way I'm supposed to read this
here oh hey plea I got to thank
everybody who bought Court McCown's
Comedy album uh people who didn't get it
can get it at www.allthingscomedy.com
uh the podcast Network for the people
um
oh and by the way next week we have some
old friends are returning
some old friends
not going to be returning to the uh the
advertising portion of the program
uh you might uh how can I tease it they
are a game of skill wink wink
um and we're happy to have them back
they're good sports about it all right
so uh I will I will respect their copy
as much as I can
all right
all right there you go
quick advertising you running my Yap
every [__] week just read the copy
bill you dumb [__]
um all right let's let's keep moving
here
um
so anyways what a [__] week what a
[__] Sports week
um tennis fans or even non-tennis fans
US Open starts this week starts today
actually and uh
after reading that Andre Agassi book I I
feel like I can watch it much better
than I used to watch it you know what
it's funny I used to sit there I used to
get tired when I used to love watching
women's tennis aside from the fact that
they were hot
you know running around with your
[__] little skirts on there
um it was only the best two out of three
so I could sit there and watch the whole
[__] thing uh the men's set when it
would go five [__] sets I'd be like
Jesus Christ is you know three four
hours
and now that I've actually read
Augustine's book because I'm such a
self-involved douchebag I never sat
there and wondered like wait a minute
like a football game takes three hours
baseball game takes three hours but you
don't get the ball every [__] play
these guys are like running backs
running the ball for three to four hours
um
I don't think I ever
fully appreciated
the physical condition that you have to
be into uh
to play that game so I'm really excited
to um
to watch it this year you know even like
the earlier rounds or whatever now that
I I can't recommend that book enough and
I feel like I've recommended it so much
I'm starting to know you guys so I'm
gonna get off the subject I watched a
little baseball this week I actually
watched the Yankees Braves game I keep
missing the games where they're scoring
like 20 runs and then they have like the
[__] outfielder coming to pitch but
uh
I gotta tell you man I am envious
of what uh the Yankees have done man
like they they kept that two number one
uh prospects
that kid bird and then their pitcher I
got to watch that kid 21 years old man
[__] crushing it on the mound
um and then some guy in the in the
broadcast Booth goes you know you know
this is not what they used to do they
used to always try to buy it and blah
blah blah blah and it's just like no
they've done this before
when George Steinbrenner got suspended
because he got suspended
they ended up not trading away Posada
I don't think they ever would have
traded away Jeter but Jeter Bernie
Williams
Andy Pettit Jorge Posada and Mariano
Rivera if George steinburner did not get
suspended there's no [__] way he
wouldn't have traded away at least three
of those and one of them would have I
bet he would have traded away Mariano
Rivera
because at first they had him pitching
like you know seventh and eighth Innings
or whatever he wasn't a [__] starter
he would have tossed him he definitely
would have got rid of Andy Pettit
Christie did it anyways
Bernie Williams he would have probably
got an impatient with or Jorge Posada
would have just tossed in there
he would have made some dumb move like
that so
I don't know I I just feel like the way
Tampa is doing it and the way Kansas
City is doing it
um
I think was always the way to do it it's
still the way to do it I just think what
the Yankees did and then the Red Sox
you know doing it too and a couple other
teams I mean
you're just not successful when you do
it for the most part and then you've
blown 180 to 200 million dollars look at
us how much [__] money did we spend
we had 12 and a half games out of first
just Walling her around in the [__]
cellar
so
I mean I don't hate the Yankees the way
I used to it's over we won three World
Series I mean it's the [__] movie
ended when we came back in o4 and won
the World Series it was over you know
what I mean I'll always not like them
but they don't have that that [__]
thing that they can hold over us anymore
but
um
despite that I'll always you know not
like the Yankees but
um
I I always respect the team when they
when they do something the right way so
I'm I'm kind of psyched that they're in
it in Kansas City
is [__] crushing it because some of
my faith the most favorite baseball I
ever watched was those late 70s early
80s
um
back before they had the wild card and
it was for the American League pennant
the LCS
those Yankees uh Kansas City ones Kansas
City can never beat the [__] Yankees
and then they finally did in 1980 and I
was so goddamn psyched because we could
never beat him and then of course they
lost to the Phillies in the World Series
but one horrific call five years later
they beat the Cardinals
um anyways
plowing ahead here
um I saw a really annoying ad on the
side of a bus today
as I was ending my bike ride
um
it was this thing on the side of a bus
about wearing condoms
and it was two guys
and then a woman in the middle
and she was both telling them
to have some willpower and use a condom
and once again with all the bitching out
there about all the sexist
[__] [__] out there I guess maybe
that's sexist because like what you were
gonna have a threesome with these two
guys
so maybe I guess women could [__] on
that level but as a guy I'm sitting
there looking at it thinking about all
the women
that I got with like how many times
right the moment of truth and you go to
reach for the condom have you been with
the woman who would go oh God I hate
condoms we just sort of whisper that and
literally you'd feel like that [__]
in your [__] stomach in your heart at
the same time like yeah I think I'm
putting on two
think I'm putting on two over there
unless of course you were drunk you'd be
like yeah
I have no idea where it just cut up I
moved my [__] uh
God damn it I moved my computer
fortunately I only talked for a couple
of seconds there
I was talking about that condom I don't
know where the [__] I left you out here
um I was just thinking how funny would
it be if they actually how long would
that ad last
if they put a woman there and on in that
ad and the guy's reaching for the condom
and the woman said oh God I hate condoms
you could never have it
they would be flipping the [__] out oh
by the way you know I watched um
I watched a little bit of the uh Christ
who the hell is playing the Raiders what
a [__] uniform by the way I'm gonna
I'm saying right now that's the best
uniform in sports
best unit of silver and black come on
man you can't [__] with that
I swear to God now that Al Davis is gone
if any douche comes along and [__] with
that emblem or those colors
you know I felt bad for Raider fans as
they were they were holding those signs
up once again stay in Oakland
you know what I mean why do they put
those fans through that [__]
you know what I mean
[__] babies man you started in
Oakland they love you why don't you Pony
up and [__] give a little bit of
money towards your own [__] Stadium
you [__] instead of holding you a fan
base
hostage like that
so ridiculous what the [__] they put
those fans through you know anyways
every 20 years yeah we're gonna leave go
[__] yourself
um
so anyway so I'm watching and they're
playing the Cardinals and they were
showing the the first female coach then
the first female referee and then you
know I'm watching Fox and they had
ladies night where they had the women
all you know anchors and all that type
of stuff
and um
now that women are and then you know
they're down on the [__] field
bugging the coaches as they're running
into the locker room I'm gonna sit just
as a male football fan
now that you guys have completely
infiltrated the [__] League
you're basically at all levels I know
you're still gonna come well we're not
an owner whatever you're gonna keep
complaining all the way up to the top
can you do me a favor
just do me this favor can you not ruin
it
can you do that
can you not ruin it the way you [__]
ruin you've ruined every guys only thing
whether it was sexist or not
you know what I mean I don't give a [__]
that you're in the league I don't give a
[__] that you're coaching that you're
refer and I don't give a [__] if you own
a [__] team I don't give a [__] just
don't ruin it
okay
[__] learn how to roll with the joke
learn how to just be one of the learn
how to be [__] cool just [__] do
that just that's all I ask don't [__]
ruin it
okay every 10 [__] seconds
planing you know what I mean
but how your feelings got hurt all right
just [__]
learn how to laugh at yourself and be
one of the guys and I mean that
figuratively I don't mean that like in
any sexist [__] way just don't
[__] ruin it
not Jesus what are the [__] odds what
are the odds that they're not going to
ruin it you know what I mean and turn it
into I swear to God my biggest fear is
within 10 years the combination of
all the women that they're now going to
add into the league which they're not
doing because they like women they're
doing it because of the Ray Rice thing
they got to turn it around
that's so bad
with that Ray Rice thing
only suspending that guy for four
[__] games out of the gate when he
knocked his fiancee out and dragged her
down the hall like a [__] caveman
they [__] he [__] that thing up so
goddamn bad do you realize that within
one football season
he [__] suspends Tom Brady for four
games for absolutely nothing and is the
first female head coach I mean I coach
oh he [__] that thing up so bad that
he he this this is the way he had to
overcompensate so he could keep his 40
million dollar a year job
so anyways yeah
just don't be like just please for the
love of God
you know that broad that makes
everything about herself don't don't be
that [__] person all right just
please don't [__] do that
my biggest fear is that within 10
[__] years
with all this this
you know
talk about concussions and all that and
all the women that they're gonna now you
know the floodgates are open they're
gonna add into the league my biggest
fear
is that like within 10 years they're
going to be playing two-hand touch
or flag football and it's just
it's just going to be over
it's just gonna be over you know what I
mean
I just I don't know
just don't ruin it
can you not do that and like even like
out here like it's so [__] like
remember a long time ago like in the
writer's room of this one
show right they were on like the [__]
eighth season
and they're sitting around trying to
come up with story lines for characters
that they've written for for well over a
hundred episodes at that point you're
out of ideas
that's usually when you have a character
getting married they have a baby
the cousin comes to town like Oliver
they they mean the Brady punch they did
so many episodes they had like nine
characters on that show three boys three
girls mom and dad and Alice
and then Alice had to get a boyfriend
and it just kept going and going and
going they became a music group they
went to Hawaii they went to the Grand
Canyon and when they were finally out of
[__] ideas this [__] kid Oliver
the seventh kid the 10th character shows
up
who the [__] was he
they did one whole episode that was
about an entirely different family
that adopted a white kid a black kid and
an Asian kid
like they were just out of [__] ideas
so anyways
to show that I'm not gonna name
they were in The Writer's room they ate
nine seasons in and they had like
they're at that point where they gotta
go to Hawaii or they gotta go to the
Grand Canyon or add Oliver so they're
sitting around trying to come up with
new story lines so one of the writers is
a joke suggests that one of the
characters rapes the other character and
blah blah blah which is totally over the
top and [__] absurd
and there was a woman in the writer's
room and she [__] sued
you know what I mean
like he's making light of is he is he
really
Jesus you're really gonna sit there and
take that literally in a comedy writing
room that's what I mean
that's what I'm talking about that's my
big fear is that's gonna happen it's
like no any sort of ball breaking will
have to be done with it like I'm just
picturing guys in the locker room having
to look over their shoulder before they
make some stupid [__] joke
you know
just imagine Ken Stabler Whispering a
joke in a locker room can you even
picture that that's what I'm worried
about it's gonna ruin it it's gonna
definitely have an impact
um I in a good way but also a negative
way I just don't understand like um
but I'm truly asking this I'm not saying
this as like maybe you guys think I'm a
[__] pig here I'm just asking is
is there anything guys can just have
they can just be guys only that won't be
considered like some sort of Illuminati
sexist [__] thing that's holding
women down can they can is there a place
where guys can just hang out
and not have to look over their shoulder
and worry about offending somebody
you know what I mean where is our brunch
that's what's going to end up happening
how is it going to have to start going
to brunch
you know and then what's going to happen
is if they have a guy's only brunch it's
going to annoy women on some level and
eventually they're going to have to go
there just because we say that they
can't
it's [__] unreal they have all women
gyms I don't give a [__]
I'll try to show up there my speedo's
going oh I should be able to use an
elliptical in here too
you know I mean I don't know
and I'm also saying this too as a worker
bee I don't run any company by the way
before you get all [__] out Jesus Christ
what are you gonna do anyways let's plow
ahead ladies just don't [__] ruin it
okay
please don't do that like you'll ruined
titty bars
I used to a bit about that you know
women's just started going to titty bars
and then they would look over it you
would be like this isn't as bad as I
thought it was gonna be and I was like
yeah cause you're here
leave and it'll get a it'll get [__]
crazy again everybody's on their best
behavior because Mom's here all right
let's uh let's plow ahead here uh
uh Donald Trump all right bill
people are getting seriously worried
about Trump I see very liberal friends
of mine making posts yearning people to
not mention his name because it'll just
perpetuate what they believe would be
the downfall of the country I get that
he's a bit out there but even if he did
get elected how bad could it be I'm sure
some of your listeners are like my
paranoid friends uh should they be
worried
um
should they be worried that an absolute
dope would be in the White House how did
you like George W bush
how did you like that guy did you enjoy
when he was in the office
when you had a guy who couldn't complete
a [__] he couldn't get through a
sentence without stuttering I mean he
sounded like me that was a bit I used to
do I used to say I like George W bush
you know why he makes me feel like I
could be president too that's literally
what I felt like I was like I went to
summer school with this guy
like the president shouldn't give a guy
like me hope you know what I mean that's
all that I'm saying and I have to be
honest with you the simplistic way that
this guy talks about major things like
just bombing people in the Middle East
and the way he talks about Mexicans
stuff like that
um
there's something about him that he's
very cartoonish so I think it's very
easy to think that uh
that he isn't like a bad thing but that
thing there where he told that guy from
the uh the Latino guy he's a citizen of
the country and when they're escorting
him out that [__] white guy goes get
out of my country
what kind of an adult says that get out
of my country
like it's his sandbox I mean it's not
necessarily Trump it's the kind of
people that gravitate towards that guy
and as much as I've loved his honesty
let's forget about all the racist [__]
the guy has said
um
I I just
I I even if he wasn't racist like he
doesn't have
the intellect for that job
you know what I mean I mean you're
talking about the guy [__] he hosts a
reality show
as much as he runs around talking about
this Empire he has I don't buy it
it's like if he truly had all the money
he had and truly had all the success he
had would he really have time
to decide if if [__] Sheena Easton or
or uh Lindsey Davenport is going to make
us better see CEO for this company that
doesn't even [__] exist
you know what I mean
the one thing I will say is I've loved
his honesty and that he sticks to what
the [__] he's gonna say
and I hope it encourages more
politicians to be honest but at the end
of the day you have to have somebody in
there that has the pedigree I mean come
on dude like look at Donald Trump dude
okay just imagine him
is he's he's somebody in the NFL draft
as a quarterback
all right can this guy make all the
throws
how's his footwork
is he patting the ball
if his number one receiver is covered is
he really gonna have
the calmness in his head when he's
standing in the pocket and it's closing
in to check down to receivers two three
and four I don't think he is I don't
think he's presidential material but
um
the fact that the the kinds of people
that he's stirring up like racists
people who say get out of my country
um
he's kind of making Pat Buchanan look
like uh like John Denver
so
um
I don't think you're you're
I think you're underreacting as much as
your friends are overreacting
um I don't think any one person has the
ability to uh be the downfall of the
country obviously he doesn't have that
level of power and I actually think if
he did get elected that both Republicans
and Democrats would resent him and I
don't think that they would work with
him the same way if somebody
from one of you know the third parties
got elected they just wouldn't work with
them because it would be great for their
own argument that if you elect a guy
from this party or if you elect a guy
like this see he can't get anything done
and they would act like a bunch of
babies Republicans and Democrats because
it's really not about doing what's right
for American people it's about winning
that's all they give a [__] about it's
the same way why I won't watch it like a
debate on CNN or fox or
or any of those shows even like Bill
Marshall real time which is kind of
outside of that [__] so much of watching
that when you listen to people argue
they're not listening to the other
person they're thinking about their next
point and they just want to win
and um I don't know I find all of that
[__] like gives me a headache
you know it's kind of like um
I don't know like my [__] wife
watches those goddamn reality shows all
the time you know come home and it's
just like 10 women screaming at each
other right and then it's bad enough she
watches that show then she watches the
show with that dude there
um
whatever his [__] name is and then
it's like they do the recap of the
series and then that [__] guy
he just brings up all the bad [__] that
they said about each other and stirs
them up all over again
and uh it's like why the [__] would I
want to sit here and what listen to 10
women screaming at each other
for the life of me I'll never understand
why my wife watches that [__] you know
of all the [__] out there that you know
you know making women look bad like
those [__] shows where they're just
walking around
with their dumb with their [__]
horseshoes like they're going down to
the club and they're still 21 trying to
get a boyfriend and they're in their 50s
it's like when are you gonna grow up
get yourself some Flats give your toes a
break for the last 30 years of your life
you know all right passion for cars
dear Bill my dad uh has an older Porsche
911. he's currently restoring that he's
currently restoring and hopes to pass
pass it on to me someday wow man your
dad's [__] cool
he goes I don't exactly share the same
passion and knowledge of ah
that's the worst are you rebelling
against your dad
he goes I don't exactly share the same
passion for our knowledge for cars
especially when it comes to Porsches he
takes a lot of pride in the work he puts
into it I'm the same way with my hobbies
can you make his passion for classic
cars relatable to a guy who is perfectly
content driving in 04 Hyundai Elantra
can you describe what it's like to go
through you what goes through your mind
when you look at a classic car the
feelings and the emotions
Jesus Christ dude can you give me more
of a difficult task you obviously you
don't have a passion for it
um
what goes through my mind it's not even
what goes It's A Feeling
when you're looking at a piece of
art like I think
cars right through like uh
right through this I was talking to
Rogan about that Rogan was [__]
hilarious
the other night I saw him at the comedy
store and Joe Rogan said that American
cars they made the best looking cars
right up through the 1960s and then on
turned on a dime
in from like the mid 70s on
made the ugliest [__] cars ever for
like I don't know 10 or 15 years barring
a couple two or three
um so what I consider classic cars are
early 70s all the way back
and then there's a few cars from like
the 80s
that remind me like oh my buddy had one
of those and we got shit-faced and stuff
like that
um
I can tell you this now that I got my
truck 68 F-100 all fixed up rebuilt
engine
new exhaust system
all the lights on at work except for the
interior light when I open the door the
radio light works
brakes work
[__] starts right up when I'm driving
down the street
and I'm running through the gears
shifting on the column and I got my arm
hanging out the window this this I can't
there's it's not a describable feeling
you either love that or you don't
and I was sitting the other night at a
red light listening to my truck idling
and I am hard-pressed
to think of a better sound that I've
ever heard when you're just sitting at a
lens
and you're running through the [__]
it's just the greatest you either have
that in your blood or you don't
um
and the fact that your dad is into
Porsches I always felt that the people
who were into the European stuff
specifically the performance cars like
the guys that I've run into that are
into them are usually
you know I'm not trying to [__] on
Americans here but they're highly
intelligent
and um
you know just like the car refined
and this like I what I would do it I
would read up on those cars I'd read up
on Formula One racing
you know I read this great book called
The Limit I just don't think you're
going to be into it but it kind of talks
about uh Formula One racing
at its peak when you when somebody like
died every other race
and it talks about the Italians the
Germans and the English uh racing teams
of that time
I don't know
watch some old movies
was it Steve McQueen or was it Paul
Newman that did the Le Mans movie I want
to say it was Steve McQueen
I know you're either into it or are you
not like this there's cars out there
that I just look at like why do they
stop making this design
like I swear to God the the two-door
Sedan like
like those GTOs
the uh
uh Ford Galaxies the Pontiacs the Buicks
the two-door [__] sedans that they
had those long with the long trunks they
were the meanest looking [__] sedans
they were just the baddest looking
[__] cars
I just look at them like what the [__]
why the [__] would you stop making that
I mean
I learned on the Seinfeld shows because
about safety that they uh all the cars
today like the car that you drive if I
looked at that real quick I can't tell
the difference between that and a
[__] Lexus or a they all look like
dinner rolls to me
um
before you give up on it I would say
actually go rent a classic car
um
do you understand how the whole thing
works how the engine works and all that
once you learn how that works the
Brilliance of it
and then if you just read up on racing
and all the stuff that they do just to
try to get another hundredth of a second
maybe that'll light the fire but I don't
think I can help you if you if you don't
have a problem driving an o4 Hyundai
Elantra
I don't think there's any you know and
you know what to be honest with you
there's nothing wrong with it if you're
not into it I'm not going to sit there
and force my passion onto you
but uh I will say you know if you
if your dad ever wants to hang out let
me know
because I'd love to see that car
all right sunglasses
dear Bill my wife told me I look stupid
in aviators because I'm 34 years old and
not in high school ah God that's just
the [__] worst can you imagine if you
ever said that to her
hey you look bad in spaghetti straps
you're not [__] 21 anymore
I mean how long before she'd even
remotely consider [__] you again
um anyways uh he goes I'm not going to
send you a picture but I really don't
look bad in them uh they don't look too
flashy I never once heard anyone say
anything I've been where when I've been
wearing them
so long that it blew my mind that it was
something that bothered her what the
[__] kind of sentence is that
they don't look too flashy and I never
once heard anyone say anything period oh
you're not using capitals this helps me
I've been wearing them so long that it
blew my mind that it was something that
bothered her I think she doesn't like
that they are youthful and she sees me
in pictures in college wearing them and
assumes that I put them on I'm going to
start boozing during the day and banging
soft sixes at those days are behind me
she's being insecure right yeah she's
being an [__]
she's being an [__] dude aviators are
great there's nothing wrong with them
they're cool sunglasses and you look
cool in them it'd be one thing if you
were wearing like Z cavaricis or I don't
know
something else that's out of style that
I can't really think of at this moment
but uh no she's being an [__] she's
actually she yes she's being insecure
look dude if you were out of shape and
you were still wearing a tank top and
you had grandmother arms she's looking
out for you you know what I mean but uh
I'd have to see them are they old
but it's not like aviators ever fell off
really
the classic sunglasses
I think he should still wear them and uh
I think there is a thing that when
you're in a relationship if you're not
careful
um
there's a part of you that can say
something uh that comes from a place
that isn't
isn't positive it could come from a
place of like insecurity or resentment
um
I would guess you probably look cool in
a
you're driving down the street maybe
that bothers you
I have no idea but I mean that's pretty
pedestrian a pair of aviators I mean
that's like a pair of blue jeans I mean
that's those things are Timeless I don't
know what her problem is what does she
want you to wear those [__] old
people wrap around glasses
so she can feel okay that you're not
going down to the [__] fruit store
and uh banging the chick behind the
counter I don't know yeah [__] her I'd
still wear the glasses I just say listen
I like them
I like them and uh
you know I don't make fun of you sports
bras
what is that supposed to mean
all right computer hey Bill I don't own
a computer anymore
uh some people downgrade their phones
Ari shaffir did so and he said he's
loving not having all the distractions
of a phone in his pocket I went the
other way I'm here to tell you that it
is an absolute pain in the ass I know
you've never suggested not owning a
computer at all but boy oh boy do I wish
I had a shitty computer as opposed to no
computer I don't know what I was
thinking I should have gotten rid of my
phone when I read on my laptop
what when I read on my laptop it's
usually informative stuff my question is
do you think you could go without a
computer or a smartphone assuming you
would record
in a podcast Studio
uh
and Nia could handle anything you really
needed
I could definitely downgrade my phone
I could definitely do that
um
and I'm definitely an addict when it
comes to that type of stuff you know
looking at my phone
I wish I never went
from a flip phone to a smartphone I wish
I never did that I will tell you
now that I'm doing a show you know
writing this show and there's new drafts
and that type of stuff that's constantly
being emailed to me and everything
and uh or somebody just emailed some
notes people communicate through email
so if I couldn't get emails on my phone
I'd have to kind of be walking around so
I think at this point
I'm kind of married to it in a way I
mean I could I guess I could I could I
could do the phone thing but a computer
uh I couldn't do that no
I love going on the internet and every
any thought I had I can look up
information on it I I love having that I
just don't like the uh
I don't like having to download new
operating systems that fill up my
computer and make my computer that
totally worked fine all of a sudden
obsolete
and I know part of that is progress but
I think that a lot of it is pushing the
herd towards having to get rid of these
things
that you know who's kidding who anything
that you throw out unless it's
biodegradable which a computer certainly
is and it really hurts the environment
and I think uh you know
I don't like being a part of that but I
am I'm in the herd man when the herd
stampedes I kind of got to run with it I
guess I could do I could not do the
phone thing I could definitely do that
I've done [__] before you know in the
late 90s a couple times I got rid of
cable
and that type of thing and uh
it was pretty cool
and I had an amazing amount of free time
but I got to tell you dude I [__]
missed sports like you wouldn't believe
but um
I don't know as I've gotten older I
watch a lot less TV but maybe that's
because I got replaced by being on the
computer a lot more I don't [__] know
anyways pool or vacation home Bill
simple question my wife and I are
debating the pros and cons of having a
pool installed versus buying a home up
in Maine
uh they're actually not far in cost by
the time you dig through all the rock in
my New Hampshire backyard what are your
thoughts here I know you don't have a
pool so maybe you could tell me what you
would do uh I'd buy the house
I'd buy the house because that's going
to increase in value I would think more
so than the pool and you live in New
Hampshire and even with global warming
How much how many months out of the year
can you use the pool
you can't rent out your pool and earn
money off of it you can't you know in a
pinch just sell off your pool to save
your house uh up in Maine you could
I would say buy the house in Maine and
then with the money that you you're
earning by renting that out
up in Maine
um I would [__]
use that money towards home improvements
in your place in New Hampshire
like having a pool
there you go
oh there you go there's there's your
financial tips from a stand-up comedian
why would you listen to me when it comes
to that [__] all right that's the
podcast for this week everybody
um oh man well I gotta say the name of
this [__] drummer that this this
person sent to me Jesus Christ
I gotta tell you something dude
I've been taking these lessons right
um and I am seeing like
such a [__] Improvement
in my plane
and
um I was really feeling great about it
and then all of a sudden you know I mean
obviously I know I'm not a professional
drummer but you know your hobby you want
to get better at it it's [__]
makes you feel good right and then
somebody sent me this
[__] video
I gotta make sure Lee Pearson
this drummer dude and this guy
this [__] solo this guy does you
would have thought a guy was playing he
was getting the he was going in the
crowd going nuts like they were
listening to a guitar solo and I'm sorry
guitar soloist you know the [__] deal
on those big shows if you just [__]
take a guitar right and you just go bang
and look at the crowd they all go
they just do that [__] [__]
drums everybody goes to the [__]
bathroom during the drum solo or a lot
of people do right this [__] guy had
him going nuts like he was like he was
up there playing eruption
on guitar man so I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually put this video up I'm gonna
have that video
uh that somebody sent me on Twitter
which I really appreciate
um I hope I'm saying his last name right
Lee Pearson Jesus Christ what a [__]
beast on drums
um
and then also you know I've talked
before you you guys know I love Italians
right you gotta know that at this point
and I love their food and all so I am a
closet Italian when it comes to uh
you know a lot of [__] and uh so I'm
I you know when I get through this whole
diet thing I've always wanted to try
making like a sundae gravy which is
basically uh you just pick three four
meats that you want to Brown up in a pan
you make some [__] meatball and then
just meatballs then you throw it all in
a [__] tomato sauce and you slow cook
it
and then you make some pasta and then
you just [__] it it's just dude they
throw like [__]
spare ribs in there meatballs sweet
Italian sausage and then crazier [__]
like Anthony Bourdain had like [__]
oxtail and like that more traditional
lower grade Meats in there that you have
to cook a long time really slow to get
the flavor and get them to like be
tender I can't wait to [__] do that
so
but there's this guy uh I sent the video
to furzie
uh it's [__] hilarious well first of
all I'll let you know the YouTube video
it opens with one of the worst songs
I've ever heard in my [__] life but
when you watch this [__] guy this
Italian guy going to the grocery store
you have to see the look on his face
when he's getting his ingredients
this the look on his face like
Germans have had less serious looks on
their faces trying to win World Wars and
this guy's just picking out [__]
garlic
and like he's [__] like the look of
intensity I was crying laughing
um and this is why my appreciation of
Italians is being German mostly German
and Irish Scottish I got English Dutch
French and all that but I'm mostly you
know German Irish
and the complete lack of giving a [__]
when it comes to the food
compare like watching like Italians how
much they give a [__]
I literally I'm crying laughing
because it it just I don't know just
it's so comical compared to what I'm
used to where if everything was [__]
boiled
salt and pepper and you just turned it
on high and cook the [__] out of it now
I know that there was some good Irish
Cuisine and German cuisine before I
gotta listen all your [__] [__]
moaning and complaining but don't even
try to remotely act that there's any
dish in Scotland Ireland England
uh uh the Netherlands
Germany
I can't say France because they have
some good food
but all those other countries there's
not one all of your best dishes combined
can't [__]
with with it's just just a [__] bowl
of pasta and some sauce in Italy you
know it's true I know it's true
so I'm watching this guy making this
[__] thing and it's in his [__] it's
a bunch of older guys and I I love old
guys with their corny [__] jokes like
one of them he was making some marriage
joke he goes hey he goes you know when
you get married there's the three rings
there's the engagement wing and the
engagement ring the wedding ring and the
suffering and they're like [__] loud
I love old guy corny [__] jokes and
he's having his buddies over
and he makes this unbelievable [__]
me only all sit down eating it and then
they all talk about like this reminds me
of my mother's cooking this is as good
as my mother's and like that's like the
highest level compliment the whole
[__] thing is just awesome and uh you
gotta watch this video
um
and it doesn't even look that difficult
as far as like the ingredients aren't
that difficult it's of course all about
the way that you uh season it and the
guys catch phrases as he's doing he just
keeps looking at the camera he goes blah
blah blah and that's all the flavor and
he looks at the camera he's like
how you doing you know and he does it
like 50 times it's funny the first seven
times and then it starts getting old and
then he just keeps doing it so many
[__] times that it literally becomes
funny again
um I don't know it just made me want to
I gotta go I gotta go I gotta go to
Italy at least go to Little Italy
something anyways so anyways that's a
podcast for this week can I say anyways
any more times that's a podcast for this
week thank you guys for listening um
hey don't sleep on that Michigan Utah
game on Thursday you know Utah's going
to come out and try to break [__]
Michigan's heart and be like no it's
going to be more the same and I know
there's a lot of people that come from
pro football cities that don't watch
college football you got to get into it
man just pick an SEC team uh I always
watch the LSU Tigers and I'm gonna watch
I'm gonna try to watch some Auburn games
this year too I'm so [__] psyched
so [__] psyched and in the middle of
all that is football's going on the
pennant races are getting Tighter and
you got two weeks of the U.S open the
last major of the Year okay if you're
bitching this time of year I don't I
can't [__] help you I can't help you
go hang out with that dude who can't
appreciate the classic cars why did I
take a dig at you I'm sure you're into
something else that I'm not into you
probably like those uh
I don't know those X-Men movies ah such
a [__] all right go [__] yourselves I'll
talk to you next week